.
Let us represent some equations
Let's assume that I have the equation y <
= 4x ​​+ 3
On the x and y axes, we want to illustrate all x and y points
Which fulfills the requirement here
A good starting point is probably to separate these less from
Or equal, because we know how to represent y
= 4x ​​+ 3
If this is equivalent to y <
4x + 3, or y = 4x + 3
This is meaning less than or equal to
It can be less than or equal to the phrase
And the reason I did it in the first example
Is because I know how to represent it
Let us represent it
.
I will try to paint better than that
If this is - no, this is not good
This vertical axis, ie y axis
This is x-axis, here
Then we know the intersection y
The intersection of y is 3
If point 0, 3 - 1, 2, 3 - fall on the line
We know that tilt 4
Know that inclination 4
Which means that if we move 1 in the direction of the x axis, we will move
Up on y axis by 4
1, 2, 3, 4
If you will be here
It is enough to draw a line
We can also refer to the X axis
If we return 1 on the x axis
We will go down by 4
1, 2, 3, 4
This will also be a point on the line
The best attempt at drawing this line will look like
So - this is the hardest part
It will look like this
This is the line
It has to be straight
I think you absorbed the idea
This is the graphic representation of y = 4x + 3
Now let's think about what it means to be less than that
All these points verify this
Equation, but we have more
These are the points here
What about points when y <4x + 3?
Let me think what this means
Let's choose some values ​​for x
When x = 0, how much is y?
When x = 0, this means that y will be
Less than 0 + 3, ie y <3
When x = -1, how much would y?
4 × -1 = -4, + 3 = -1, if y
Will be less than -1
When x = 1, how much y?
4 × 1 = 4, + 3 = 7
If y <
Let's try to appoint them at least
When x = - let us identify these first, when x
= 0, y <3
x = 0, y <3
If it is all these points - I shading them
In green - check the equation
If you want to look at this, when x = -1
The y <-1
If y here are all these points at the bottom
After x = 1, y <7
It's all about these points
All in all, we take any point on x - let's assume we will take
This point x
If we value 4x + 3, we get the point
On-line
Which is a value x multiplied by 4 + 3
Now the values ​​of y that achieve the equation can equal those
The point on the line, or it can be less than
Which will be down the line
If you want to do this for all possible x values
You will not only get the values ​​on the line
We draw it, but we will also get the lines that fall below the line
We have now represented this equation
It is about this line, 4x + 3, with all the space
The shaded net is below
Now, if the code is limited to less than just, not less than or equal to
In this case, we do not include the same line
The agreement on this is to make the line
Dotted
This case if we deal with less code
From 4x + 3
Because in this case, these do not apply, and
We will only get these
If the line itself will not achieve it, but
The space that lies below it
Let's do one like this
Suppose we have y> -x
/ 2-6
And the best way to start - the way you'd better start out
The issues - is that I graphically balance the equation
Let me paint, let me represent y
= - This is equivalent to 1/2 - 6
If we want to represent it, this vertical axis, this
Horizontal axis
The y-intersection is -6
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
This intersection is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
The inclination is 1 / 2-
Oh, x should be here, 1 / 2x - 6
If the tilt is 1/2, it means that when it moves 2 to
Right, I'll move down by 1
If I move to the right by 2, I will move down by 1
If you move 2 by left, ie to -2
I will move 1 up
If -2 and 1 are up
And the line will look like this
The line will look like this
This is the best I can draw
If this is the line for y
1 / 2x- 6
Now, the equation that we have is not greater than or equal to, but it is
Larger than x / 2 - 6, or larger
From 1 / 2x to 6
Using the same logic, for any x - so
I took any value for x, let 's assume that for the x value we want to
We choose - if we value x / 2 - 6
We will get this point
We'll get a point on the line
But the y values ​​to which this equation is equal are y values
Which are even bigger
This point will not be - in fact, will draw
Open circle - because you can not include a point
1 / 2x- 6
But all y values ​​will be greater than that
All y values ​​are bigger than that
This is true for any x value
We take this x
We estimate 1/2 or x / 2 - 6
We get this point
The y values ​​that achieve the equation are all the values ​​of y that lie higher
If all y values ​​are achieved by this equation, or all
The axes that achieve the equation are all this space
Which is located above the line
We will not include this line
If the agreement draw this line it is to have a line clip
Let me draw - I will do what I can to make it
Dashed line
I will erase parts of the line, and I hope it is
It will look choppy
I turn this line connected to the intermittent line Hannah I see you
It's just a limit, but it's not included within
Values ​​that achieve the equation
The values ​​that make up the equation are all of these
The yellow area I shaded above the line
Anyway, I hope you found this useful